♪ ♪ ♪
- Le centre-ville de Montréal
t peu à peu les jours
de semaine. On le constate aux
heures de pointe, dans les rues,
dans le métro où l'achalandage
ente maintenant 53 %
de ce qu'il était en 2019.
On le voit aussi le midi, nes f,
comme ici au pied de
la Place Ville-Marie.
- Très contenllègues, revoir unu
de la vie, des restos, manger
autres choses que du surgelé
à la maison!
- C'est génial, ça fait
du bien de voir des gens,
d'entendre du bruit.
d'équipe. On voit qu'il y
a beaucoup plus e
maintenant avec les équipes
dans lesquelles on travaille.ere
de Montréal, environ 50 000
travailleurs se déplacent
actuellement au centre-ville
350 000 avant la pandémie.
MICHEL LEBLANC, président
Chambre de commerce de Montréal
- Dans les chiffres, ce qu'on
du nombre d'employés qui ont
amorcé leur retour. On est
rendus à 61 %; on était à 47 %
en août et à 28 % en juin.
C'est souvent une fois
par se fois même,
une fois par deux semaines. prir
le télétravail est maintenant
levée et la plupart des
entrepleur plan de retour.Ce 21r
Pomerleau souhaitait
la bienvenue à
Ils doivent désormais passer
une ou deux journées
par semaine au bureau.
Jordi Lamarre venait déjà sur
une base volontaire jusqud
ou trois jours par semaine.
JORDI LAMARRE,
- Je suis content.
se que le retour
au travail va faire
du bien au nivea
va vraiment être un modequi vaq,
personnellement. Je pense qu'ilr
une certaine flexibilité.
mois serviront à expérimenter
les noaires hybrides
des 300 employés.
ISABELLE POULIOT, v.-p. exerleau
- Éventuellement, ce qu'on vises
trois jours par semaine
au burune option qui est viable
à long terme parce que
ça permet, je crois,
suffisamment de collégialité
temps, il y a des tâches qu'on
fait de façon plus efficace
quand on est concentré chez soi.
- Les entreprises sont
d'ailleurs nombr
envisager un avenir hybride,
chez Hydro-Québec, par exemple,
du centre-ville reviendront
graduellement en
CAROLINE DESROSIERS,
porte-parole, Hydro-Québec
leur présence au bureau va être
requismaine
minimum et, ensuite, on va
déployavail qui va être flexibls
fonctions de chacun, mais
en moyenne, ça va êtreun troun l
par semaine.
♪ ♪ ♪aisse de dépôt demandera,
elle, trois jours par semaine
en présentiel à ses employés.
Les mardis et mercredis seront
obliga
tout le monde se retrouve.
À la Sun Life, les 2200 employés
auront carte blanche :
travailler sur place.
- Le décrochage anticipé, là,
c'est à peu près 25 %.- À termee
par la Chambre de commerce
démontre que le centre-ville
pourrait perdre un travailleur
télétravail. Pour les petits
commerçants qui
c'est une donnée inquiétante.
MCIHEL LEBLANC, président
- Quand on regarde dans
les galeries marchandes,
un commerce sur trois.
Au pied des tours à bureaux
dans les espaces, c'est 40 % à
peu près. Et durant l'année,
ce qui est inquiétant,
c'est que ça a diminué.- Malg- -
pandémique, il y a aujourd
4 % moins de petits commerces
ouverts au centre-ville qu'il
y en avait au début de l'année.
- Ce que ça témoigne, c'est ce
les commerçants se rendent
un peu au bout d
au bout de liquidités
et finissent par tomber
viande, il y a les spaghettisal.
- Le petit restaurant
de Rino Massinori, rue Stanley,
qui s'en vient sera critique.
RINO MASSIRONI,
propriétaire, Café Presto
tranquille. Disons... on fait
une monts
par jour au lieu d'avoir
35 ou 30. J'ai u
le propriétaire disons comprend
tout çirer!bonne nouvelle pour .
Selon la Chambre de commerce,ree
en proer
presque au temps